welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Marvel's
what if season 2 episode 7 what if hella
found the 10 rings I'm back people well
sort of I'm still technically on
paternity leave after my baby boy was
born earlier this month and a huge
thanks to Jessica to John to everyone on
the new Rockstar team for covering for
me but I'm just back for now filling in
for Jess for this one episode just to
give her a breather because she's been
working so hard and you are going to
start to see me a bit here and there in
the next week before I am back full-time
in early January but we got to talk
about this episode because what if hella
found the T Rings finally gets to the
bottom of that growl Odin gave to Loki
father hey and it's because Asgard Santa
Claus is a real turd I'm going to break
down this episode scene by scene for all
the Easter eggs the animation details
and one huge missing piece of the MCU
puzzle that this episode finally answers
about the origin of the 10 Rings we're
going to get to it we open with the
ceiling Fresco in the Palace of Asgard
the one that Hela uncovered with Scourge
and Thor Ragnarok after Odin had
wallpapered over her history as the
original wielder of munir and Odin's
executioner in its conquest of the nine
Realms before Thor was ever born now
those nine Realms are actually depicted
in the form of these nine sigils in the
upper left corner here of these I'm not
sure which of these sigils is which but
the nine Realms are Asgard midgard AKA
Earth yodenheim SAR alheim aka the Dark
World vanaheim ner musim and alheim
which is home of the light elves like
that one little butthole we met in
shehulk in this art Hela rides the wolf
Fenris based on Fen reer in Norse
mythology Odin has its triet ra symbol
before him that's what appeared on mnir
when he whispered his incantation into
it and we see Odin carrying his spear
gungir which becomes an important
McGuffin later in the story but most
importantly Odin is wearing a different
Crown than we've seen before this is
actually a very similar antler design as
the headpiece worn by Hela so really
hela's overall appearance isn't like a
villainy that's unique to her she really
inherited this thorniness from her
father and I love how in this ceiling
painting the ring border of it is moving
the bifrost bridge is shimmering the
Halo behind 's head and her closeup is
rotating as well so at one point this
art was really alive in order to show
the cycle of Asgardian history because
yeah it is a cycle things like Ragnarok
is really part of a repeating event in
Norse mythology The Watcher says in a
campaign of Fire and Blood Fire and
Blood is also the name of George R
Martin's historical text that formed the
basis of the House of the Dragon series
on HBO Which documents the inner
conflicts of the Targaryen Dynasty
during the dance of the dragons and that
drama similarly begins when a father
denies his firstborn daughter the throne
due to some patriarchal it's
just so interesting to see Hela this
episode transition from a western
mythological tradition Norse mythology
to a world with roots in eastern
mythology the 10 Rings the realm of talo
and in doing so unlocks a greater power
that she was denied in her
male-dominated world this prologue also
focuses on the societies that Odin and
Hela conquered including cultures akin
to the frost Giants of yenim and the
dark elves of spart alheim joining Odin
and Hela in this Conquest were the
valkyrie are that's the Legion of
Pegasus riding Warriors that Valkyrie
belonged to and the ones whom Hela
attacked when she was in hell we saw
that in Ragnarok and I think they show
us all this at the beginning of the
episode in order to show Asgard not
presented as they've normally been as
Heroes but rather as mass murderers much
like Thanos in the black order Kate
Blanchett returns to voice Hela in this
episode and we see the moment Odin
banished her to hell for wanting to
continue their Conquest beyond the nine
Realms apparently that dispute involved
Hela killing a bunch of Odin soldiers
because yeah Heim doll's Observatory is
carpeted with corpses here The Watcher
says the Alla imprisoned her in hell and
it's spelled h e l l in the closed
captions which is weird because we know
from the close caption in Loki season 1
episode 4 that an H Hell exist in the
MCU hell with one L is really known as
the Norse afterlife for punishment but
it seems like according to the Watcher
they're one in the same while you could
say the First episodes of the season
have ignored the classic one alter
detail element of the whatif format
these recent episodes have really
returned to form instead of banishing
hella to Hell Odin goes further breaking
Muir and banishing Hela to midgard
placing a similar spell on her helmet
that he placed on m in the very first
Thor film so really the what if scenario
here is what if Hela rather than just
being banished out of sight and out of
mind was given the Thor treatment and
walk through those story beats and learn
from a society but not a society of like
New Mexico astronomers and
astrophysicist but from win wo in the
society the 10 rings but also instead of
a worthiness charm it's a charm based on
Mercy whosoever wears this Crown should
she know Mercy shall possess the power
of hel this poses a really interesting
question like if others like Steve
Rogers had always been worthy of Muir
who else in the MCU could have had an
innate Mercy enough to Dawn hela's Crown
like Captain Carter Wanda maximoff she's
already got a tiara also does it have to
be a she and I love how Odin catches me
the same way Hela does and throw
Ragnarok and the fracture lines The
Broken Pieces hit the ground just like
they do in that film also this noise
that Odin makes as he throws the crown
reminds me of the snarl that he makes at
Loki
hey so whereas Thor landed in New Mexico
in a pillar of bifrost light hella crash
land ends in a fiery smoke Trail kind of
like the angel Lucifer being cast out of
heaven and crash landing but Hela
arriving in China this way actually
aligns with the origin of the 10 Rings
The prologue to the shangi film
speculated that wiwo found them in a
crater hel's Crown takes the place of
Muir as the artifact that is in this
storm swept Crater from the 2011 Thor
film and I love how you always see hel's
reflection reflected in that helmet as
if her own appearance is there
reflecting back at her taunting her lack
of Mercy but it would only reflect that
if it had been Co in rain so because the
Norse gods are so associated with storms
you know you have the God of Thunder
every boom is it's supposed to be some
other Norse God fighting with another
Norse godod that slick rain is what
reminds Hela that she is no longer part
of that Pantheon thank you to Better
Health for sponsoring this video you can
love holiday season and also admit that
it's stressful travel time with family
marking time with New Years it can be a
lot and if you feel like you could use a
little help with it all try connecting
with a licensed therapist by using
better help starting therapy can be hard
the right therapist for you may not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face to-face interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat even via messaging if you
prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with a therapist from
their Network that's right for you if
you don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist for no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who's in your network or
anything like that if you think that you
might benefit from therapy consider
betterhelp click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com neww
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of Better
Health so that you can connect with a
therapist and see if it helps you so we
see win woo with five of the 10 Rings
glowing blue on his wrist which is a
similar Gunslinger pose that we saw of w
Wu in the flashback prologue of the
shanii film The Watcher says like the 10
rings that fueled his power Shu and woo
knew all too well the most powerful
forces on Earth often come from Beyond
and when we looks up at the stars which
tells us that his 10 Rings fell to Earth
from the cosmos after the opening
credits The Watcher even doubles down
and says something far more intriguing
had fallen from the heavens so it's
suggested that the 10 rings in every
Universe fell from the sky Hela here's W
wo's men speaking Chinese and she speaks
back to them in Chinese but when w wo
response to her it's in English so
they're both multilingual while hela's
status as an Asgardian might be what's
giving her the knowledge of all the
languages of midgard wi Woo's similarly
extended life has made him this sort of
Multicultural Godlike figure by the way
wi woo this episode is voiced by Fodor
chin an actor that I actually know from
the LA comedy scene and a prolific actor
and voice actor you goio good job man
Hela brushes her hair back but no antler
Crown extends the way it would have if
this were Thor Ragnarok and Hela gets
punched across the face in slow motion
which reminds us of the first time
another green cloaked Norse demigod got
hit this way in the opening minutes of
the Loki episode 1 like the Loki Series
this so takes a Thor villain and
reassigns their glorious purpose from
selfishness to Noble heroism Loki
transitioned from the god of Mischief to
the god of stories Hela goes from the
goddess of death to the goddess of light
or Liberation either way you love to see
it Hela pretends to beg wimo soldiers to
quote show Mercy on her forgetting that
Odin had just banished her for her
inability to show Mercy when wo binds
Hela with the 10 rings and she says that
power it is not of this realm nor are
you so let's talk about what this
episode is telling us about the 10 rings
the Marvel's film disproved the theories
that the 10 Rings might have had a cre
origin so at that point we just started
to assume well they probably had some
connection to Kang right well now I'm
wondering if these 10 Rings might have
had an Asgardian origin another one of
Odin's lost relics instead of summoning
Kang the Rings could be summoning the
northcott of stories in idril like these
Rings just automatically call to the
closest thing the universe has to an
Alla like notice how later Odin says the
10 rings do not belong in these
primitive hands I think the implication
is that Odin is at least familiar with
these Rings or he might have actually
owned them in the past that could be why
they glow the same colored blue as the
Tesseract in the casket of ancient
Winters so we replay the events of the
2011 film here like Thor struggling to
lift Moler in the rain Hela is now
screaming in agony at her failure to
lift this Crown from the crater and I
love how they even animated the same
slow motion raindrop flinging off her
hair just like how Kenneth Bros shot
that scene in the film and was so over
the top but awesome winw now takes a
liking to Hela and invites her to kind
of culturally appropriate but he's says
that red is seen as a color of good
fortune and that brides wear it on their
wedding days and red was featured so
prominently in the wardrobes of shuni
and the Warriors of talo and W Wu's wife
Yin Lee is wearing red when they get
married take their photo this episode
has set at least 1500 years in the past
long before W Wu would meet Ying Lee
because Hela was banished by Odin before
Thor was born Thor is 1500 years old in
this episode Hela refers to Thor's
mother frga as Odin's new girlfriend so
Thor hasn't even been born yet Hela
attacks win wo tears off her sleeves she
fle on the rooftops and the imagery
reminds me a lot of Ang Le's Photography
in Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon when
Jen steals the green Dynasty sword and
Glides through the rooftops some amazing
wirework there that film obviously a
huge influence on the shung chief film a
film that brought back Michelle yo in a
less significant role but you know it
would be a sin to not include her at all
in that movie and I love how Hela is
running toward a full moon and it is
shaded green which is her natural color
but she falls from it this episode shows
Hela having to unlearn that gree means
go and kind of stop seeing red as a
stoplight Hela meets Morris the adorable
furry pet from Tallow that was kept by
Trevor Slattery in the shuni film Morris
leads her through that same Enchanted
bamboo forest that he led shuni and
Katie and Trevor through but this maze
leads her directly into Tallow there is
no extra step of the waterfall cave like
we saw in that film so I'm wondering if
in these 1500 years they might have
added this extra step because people
were just like successfully completing
the maze by accident Hela says I've not
survived a thousand years of war to die
at the hands of foliage I don't know
maybe it's just me I think it's an
interesting line considering Loki's fate
after thousands of years will be in the
roots in the vines of foliage the edril
tree Hela gets attacked by zi and Morris
tries to warn her right yeah it kind of
sounds like Morris purred right behind
XI is wearing the same green dress in
wide brimmed bamboo hat in the mask that
Ying Le wears when she first fought WN
Wu and shuni she uses similar air bendy
Magic and was probably part of the same
lineage when Hello wakes up she sees a
flock of phoenix-like Firebirds these
are Fen hangs and we saw these in talo
in the shuni film among all the other
mythological creatures heimall notices
that Hela disappeared from his view
she's off the grid and the fact that he
and Odin are so shocked by this suggests
to us that the magic of talo represents
a realm with a kind of competing claim
on earth like it's separate from the
magical forces of Asgard and that other
than Asgard there are other Godlike
mythological forces that have a stake in
Earth's success or might be trying to
conquer Earth there's just like deeper
unexplored Horizons Beyond talo and all
those ancient civilizations that
Michelle Yo's character talked about in
the shung film so so they agree to train
Hela and to keep her in check they show
her the great protector Dragon whom we
remember fighting the dweller in
darkness in the shanii film Heim doll
reports to Odin that Hela went off the
grid and that she's near the 10 Rings we
see that Odin's Throne has twin snake
heads this Golden Throne did not look
like this in the 2011 Thor film so this
era of Odin truly is a more aggressive
era of Odin this is not the Odin we know
ja teaches Hela uh forgive me if I
mispronounce this Jaa which is the term
for Chinese paper folding it's not to be
confused with the Japanese origami J
calls it the art of making something out
of nothing now the Chinese are one of
the world cultures known to have
invented paper along with the Egyptians
who of course use Papyrus a unic scribe
of the Han Dynasty named Kyon was
attributed with this paper making
technique back in 202 BCE to 220 CE so
even this paper itself was the Chinese
making something out of nothing J goes
on of Finding infinite possibility in
the blankest of canvases H this sounds
like something The Watcher would say we
are seeing Hela evolve from May warrior
with a fixed mindset to a growth-minded
artist that's open to new ideas and new
shapes the Multiverse can fold into Z
uses the discipline of laundry to break
down hela's desires returning her to
this childhood memory when Odin first
leashed a puppy version of Fenris and
Hela realizes it's not the 10 Rings or
The Throne of Asgard that she wants but
instead freedom freedom from control the
freedom to choose my own path and for
once notice how Kate blanchett's voice
transitions from hotty and privileged to
just ay and unburdened now this
education and training montage may feel
like the Trope we've seen too many times
Doctor Strange Batman Begins Iron Fist a
privileged white person goes to the Far
East to learn their wisdom and then
comes out of it as their enlightened
champion and somehow better at it than
they are yeah I think we've all had
enough of that but at least in this case
it's a goddess learning that the Mortal
approach to existence is better
sometimes messy humanity is better than
Divine Perfection when Hela goes off to
confront Odin her talo armor is mostly
red but with Green Bamboo strips woven
through these colors reflect the way
Hela has embraced the red Fortune color
of her new environment but holds it
together with that green Warrior spirit
that she still can't part ways from now
I don't know about you I thought it was
kind of weird that Odin begins this
episode scolding Hela for not showing
enough Mercy for not joining him and
ending the conquest but then just merely
upon learning that this Chinese warlord
and his daughter have the 10 Rings he
reverts to his old conquering ways and
becomes a huge prick I think it's just a
reminder that Odin 1500 years ago was
more of a temperamental you
could also say maybe he doesn't want any
of midgard's cultures other than his
chosen Norse people to have access to
these God weapons which e yikes that
would be really shitty Odin but I guess
it's also worth remembering that all
those gods of omnipotent City
really seem to only care about their
particular people who worship them
because it is a society that worships
them that gives them their power this is
exactly how Santa Claus works I'm not
saying it's right I think Gore should
have killed all these guys but it does
inform their old problematic selfish way
of thinking Hela tells win wo that they
need to get gungir Odin has had this
spear since the first Thor film and it
actually comes from Norse mythology it's
known as the Spear of the heavens or
really the Swain one is what it
translates to it can Pierce whatever
it's thrown at but this I believe is the
first time in the MCU the term gungir
was actually used like Tony cap and Thor
teaming up against Thanos in ingame Hela
and win wo joined together in these
well-timed coordinated strikes on Odin
remember before Thanos Odin was
considered the Thanos as conqueror of
that time that's why Thanos waited to
move until right after Odin died at one
point we see win wo using five of the
Rings to pry the spear out of Odin's
hands when Wu does this again later to
move the spear into hela's hands I just
love the fight animation here and gungir
accidentally creates these fire knives
that Hela flings at Odin which
frustrates him so that he grabs one of
the 10 Rings which shocks win wo but it
proves Odin's strength as all father and
his possible connection to these Rings
origin but this decision to grab one of
the Rings is what Hela exploits she uses
a more passive maneuver that she learned
from zi to weave down Odin's Spear and
slip it out of his grasp and now with
Odin exposed when woo put puts all the
10 rings on one wrist and punches them
right in the cheek Hela offers Odin
mercy and while Odin rejects it that
choice is what rattles hela's Crown
deactivates the mercy charm and the
crown returns to her and it transforms
her giving her new bright silver armor
and at this sight Odin cannot help but
concede and in the end you eclipsed even
my wildest expectations you eclipsed me
I like the idea of her being the goddess
of light because it would tie in with
Odin using this astronomical term
Eclipse to describe the power shift
because the north gods have always been
associated with the Stars and Heavenly
Bodies so the Watcher explains that this
alliance between the armies of Asgard
and the 10 Rings created an Empire of
liberators we see these liberators
charging in zob B that's a civilization
that Thanos called in the flashback of
infinity War gamora's people and we're
seeing the moment that Thanos took y
Gamora under his wing a moment that we
know was so important to him that is
what he saw the moment he snapped that's
where he went this right here is one of
thanos's Nexus moments and it's so
thematically important that this episode
comes back to this moment because Thanos
using gamorra as his executioner and
then disposing her is basically what
this era of Odin is doing to Hela but
the Watchers narration suggests that
even Thanos can change from this moment
on like we know that universes exist
where Thanos is a good guy and season
one's what if tala became Star-Lord it
was tala's innate goodness that was
enough to warm thanos's heart and in
this case it's the principles of Tallow
and the mercy forgotten by even the gods
who blessed us with it hey inspired by
what if we are rolling out a new project
in the week ahead an insanely in-depth
video series called new rock stars what
if in the first episode it's going to
explore an alternate historical timeline
in which Edgar Wright did direct Ant-Man
we're so proud of this video it's gon to
look real different from anything else
you've seen on new rockstars we're going
to talk about why things really fell
apart there and more importantly what
would have happened in the MCU if things
went differently and that plus some
other big 2024 announcements in the next
few days so if you haven't already
please watch Jessica Clemens breakdown
of episode 6 and all the other episodes
of this season subscribe to all three
channels in the new rock stars Network
support what we do by grabbing one of
our great merch designs from nerd riot.
shop you can follow and EA boss thank
you so much for watching and I'm going
to go back to taking care of my kid and
I'll see you soon thanks everybody
[Music]
bye